That's it.
You can build a simple
covenant with just this.
Stack up you convulsions, which
thankfully you don't have to implement
yourselves, then use trieds to
to reduce the dimensional ID and
increase the depth of your network,
layer after layer.
And once you have a deep and
narrow representation,
connect the whole thing to a few
regular fully connected layers and
you're ready to train your classifier.
You might wonder what
happens to training,
into the chain rule in particular,
when you use shared weights like this.
Nothing really happens.
The math just works.
You just add up the derivates from all
of the possible locations on the image.